le département vous présente terre de
trail 70 km de course et il faut déjà
quitté soboth hier que des silences pour
retrouver de la force
rien de mieux que de revenir à nos
racines des valeurs que monsieur et
madame waro partage dans leur mine et
chico
[Musique]
comme son héros bonjour jours alexandre
bienvenue à l'unesco
c'est gentil et un moment là où c'est
pas la peine appliquée à malras alors
voici où pascal d'accord mais le
chantier suit la progression qu'on l'est
où les hépatites ou les poteaux le
californien pour la potasse à capendu de
l'azoté restera d'accord tacite aux
plantes et aux que je prenais un mélange
de léchouilles selon on va faire un
mélange de pression mais pas d'amour où
les dons à nous le rival d'avoir été
derrière on va monter alors tombé
poignet va regarder tout ça par
l'originalité de cette île est et la
proximité avec un espace naturel
sensible au pied du taïbit tu la
permaculture comme elle à vrai dire que
c'est des mots pour moi le nouveau on
parle beaucoup
l'accord pourrait bien que le genre
d'erreurs et elle attend la culture on a
donné un mot nouveau dacquois pour mieux
comprendre le monde les gens comprennent
que veiller à la permaculture
c'est facile ça veut dire c'est qu'on
prend un type et l'écossé avant tout de
nous ça veut dire l'environnement la
nature c'est ramener cndd accueilli dans
leur jardin
il est automatiquement créé un
écosystème entraîne vie dans le genre
d'homme à la mer que ce monsieur n
forêts secondaires d'entendre mon grand
père tout ça elle était cultivée capable
achats dans le respect de
l'environnement
donc on sera pas mal de gens lui quelle
nature n'a pas ça veut dire les
joaillier insensibilisation bastion
environnement selon les personnes
passées les plantations
si les plantes médicinales aussi
d'accord le bus est associé tout le
monde d'accord de la fia de ne pas
commander une femme vraiment très motivé
d'accord on a des phréatiques et il fait
bon manger qui fait bon manger bien sûr
voit bien qu'on a des
je ferai ce qu'il ya de mieux et il est
très motivé aussi d'accord on va dire
que c'est pareil je prends aussi je crée
de l'emploi
c'est pas prendre les gens à avancer
comprendre l'environnement
l'alimentation des coureurs là bas ça
veut dire beaucoup j'ai passé pas mal de
trucs d'accord que moi me dit toujours
que les plans les plus puissants les
dans notre aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je
c'est super bon mais assez pour le
ravitaillement il reprend la route et
grand raid est en émoi prochaine merci
pause athénée en général et c'est
reparti
[Musique]
le département vous a présenté terre de
travail